olalla ya se extrañaba estoy de plano
la conferencia que van a ver ahorita
no es tanto una conferencia sino que
es un llamado de emergencia
la situación que estamos viviendo
ahorita definitivamente es crítica en
tema de salud no podemos decir que no
pero hay otra crisis de la cual no se
habla tanto
y estoy hablando de la crisis financiera
lo que está pasando en los hogares lo
que está pasando en las carteras de cada
uno de nosotros
este momento es importantísimo y por eso
por eso les estoy dando un llamado de
emergencia
verás no es una catástrofe pasar por una
crisis lo que es una catástrofe es pasar
por una crisis y no aprender
absolutamente nada
así que este es el llamado que ustedes
estaban esperando para tomar el control
de sus finanzas no sé si son estudiantes
no sé si son profesionistas no me
importa lo que hagan
pero se los digo claro desde ahorita
este es el momento
para que se tomen en serio la forma en
que ven usan administran
multiplican su dinero
yo soy morir y empezó el movimiento
educación financiera porque me apasionan
tanto las finanzas sabes por qué porque
las finanzas le dan el poder a las
personas las finanzas está en el poder a
ti
para ti
y ahorita lo estamos viendo nada más en
las personas sino también en las
empresas
el saber tomar buenas decisiones
financieras es
y por eso este es el llamado de
emergencia que les quiero dar hoy y hoy
en particular
les quiero decir 5 decisiones
financieras que todos nosotros tenemos
que tomar el día de hoy otra vez no
importa que te dediques no me importa
cuánto ganes no me importa
pero es importante que tomes estas cinco
decisiones financieras hoy y te lo voy a
dar por ejemplos muy prácticos con
ejecutables cosas que puedas hacer
ahorita saliendo de este auditorio
porque si no de nada sirve
de nada sirve
la primera decisión financiera que
tienes que tomar tiene que ver con
conciencia financiera y cuando digo
conciencia financiera es darnos cuenta
de la importancia de cómo nos impactan
las finanzas en nuestra vida en méjico y
un problema brutal de educación
financiera
la estadística si me lo permite
conciencia financiera la estadística que
dice siete de cada diez mexicanos tiene
problemas
siete de cada diez mexicanos no tiene
ahorros para el retiro
y si les preguntara ustedes cuántos de
ustedes conoce cómo funciona el esquema
de retiro en méxico pues en verdad me lo
podrían decir
qué es un aforo
para qué sirve porque están peleando en
el congreso para hacerle modificaciones
porque no jala
se van a empezar a presionar algunas
personas ahora los próximos años y se
van a dar cuenta que
pues es que nunca me dijeron nada
lamento decirte lo que es cierto
y nunca te dijeron nada y
desgraciadamente a muchos de nosotros
nunca nos los van a decir
este estudio amado de emergencia
entonces es importante que tomemos
conciencia maurice cómo puedo tomar
conciencia mis finanzas ejemplos y
ejercicios sencillos lo primero que
puedes hacer ahorita aterrizó un
presupuesto cuánta lana gastas en cuánta
lana ganas y en cuánto estás bien que
estás gastando en qué y en cuánto cuánto
estás gastando
definitivamente estamos viendo muchos
patrones que están cambiando ahorita
pandemia
los hábitos de consumo nuestras
dinámicas la forma en que nos movemos
cambian
porque tomas una decisión de compra y no
otra les voy a decir algo las finanzas
es algo bien curioso porque estamos
luchando contra nuestro propio ser si
alguien de ustedes ha estudiado la
materia de bigelow economics se da
cuenta que el ser humano es claramente
irracional y que preferimos comprarnos
unas papitas o hay que ahorrar para el
retiro pues porque el retiro
y preferimos la seguridad que en verdad
educarnos y ver cómo es que funcionan
las inversiones sin si nos dicen que le
metamos nuestra lana una cripto moneda
porque nos vamos a hacer millonarios de
la noche a la mañana pues eso hacemos
pero no nos metemos a investigar cómo
funcionan las cosas y cómo es que yo
desde ahorita es de estudiante puedo
empezar a trabajar
en mi patrimonio con lo poquito que
tenga no importa pero yo como voy
aportando voy haciendo inversiones
compuestas que me den ganancias
exponenciales en un mediano a largo
plazo
pero nunca nadie más y no es mucho
un presupuesto muy sencillo utilidad
personal y si tiene su negocio sácalo
rentabilidad de tu negocio cuánto vendes
a cuánto vendes costo gasto utilidad
si no me des tus finanzas no las vas a
poder mejorar y eso es todo en la vida
lo que no se mide no se mejora esa frase
la tengo tanto en mi espalda no no se
crean pero así es importante
lo que no me des no mejoras como comes
como haces ejercicio como llevas tu
dinero mide lo quiero mejorar mi de lo
es mi consejo de cinco minutos
ahora también en la parte de conciencia
de conciencia financiera yo tengo una
comunidad privada de gente que quiere
seguir aprendiendo de finales personales
me tocó el caso de luís está aquí es
luís se hizo con 7 es un es un
universitario se hizo consciente que el
compadre se gastaba 500 pesos los fines
de semana en fiestas
pues acabaron las fiestas
qué sucedió se puso se puso vivo y ya
llevamos rato en pandemia y lo que hizo
fue siempre la pasión el wellness así
que decidió comprarse una maquinita de
jugos con el dinero que empezó a ahorrar
que ya utilizaba nada más que ahora las
dinámicas cambiaron ya no lo gasta tanto
decidió comprar una maquinita y está
empezando su negocio de jugos algo tan
sencillo se hizo consciente de lo que
estaba gastando y cómo es que podía
utilizar mejor ese dinero costo
oportunidad
tú haces y dejas de hacer ve tú gastas
en vez de ahorrar tú gastas en vez de
invertir costo oportunidad uno de los
conceptos financieros más importantes
entonces luis se hizo consciente sus
finanzas muy sencillo segunda decisión
financiera que tiene que tomar el día de
hoy es saber priorizar el flujo efectivo
en un negocio lo más importante ahorita
en estos tiempos se llama flujo efectivo
no perder liquidez si pierdo y que de
liquidez pierdes tu capacidad para pagar
tus responsabilidades llámese nómina
llámese proveedores llámese lo que sea
entonces el día de hoy quiero que
ustedes se vayan con sabiendo que
significa el flujo efectivo que son
ingresos y egresos lo que entra y lo que
sale en tu negocio y en tu vida
y para esto quiero que desarrollen una
visión es bien difícil planear
financieramente en pandemia olvídate
planea financieramente a un año planea
horita tu mes dos meses tres meses
planea el trimestre que gastos
importantes tienen cómo te va a caer
landa
y checa como puedes usar instrumentos
por ejemplo una tarjeta de crédito
usarla bien
no tener intereses louis
de tarjetas que no te cobran anualidad y
es un instrumento
entradas y salidas ser conscientes de
nuestro flujo de efectivo en los
próximos tres meses si tiene negocio en
el año
entonces básicamente eso es como eso es
lo que lo que genera el flujo efectivo y
también nos tenemos que volver un
poquito más conscientes de cómo impactan
las decisiones que tomamos en nuestra
vida a nuestro flujo
no sé si ustedes en verdad saben
distinguir entre lo que verdad
necesitamos y lo que es meramente deseo
es increíble lo poco que necesita el ser
humano y como nosotros mismos le damos
en la torre a nuestras finanzas les ha
pasado
necesitamos un carro para mover maurice
compró un carro nuevo
empiezo invertir o invierte en un
terreno para que el carro si tienes un
carro bien bonito yo lo vi
y te mueves
y te mueves pregúntate cómo está
cambiando la pandemia la forma en que
ves las cosas no solamente el dinero
sino también la vida
número 3 decide tener previsión
financiera que es la palabra perdón pero
en las finanzas es la más importante
ahora resulta que a todos les gusta
hablar de la bolsa y les gusta hablar de
cripto monedas las finanzas es de espada
y escudo si vas por lo que quieres
inviertes y más lana más pero primero en
la protección primero la previsión
financiera entonces la pandemia
definitivamente
nos llama a tener previsión financiera
maurice qué significa tener previsión
financiera desde sabes que olvídate de
invertir ahorita tu lana primero cubre
tu ahorro de emergencias entre 3 y 6
meses de tus gastos fijos y después
ahora si generas tus inversiones a largo
y corto plazo
dadas sus metas financieras cualquiera
que ésta sea primero define las que
quiere ser que escriban la maestría
quieres irte de viaje quieres comprar su
primera casa quieres invertir en un
negocio cuánta lana necesitas ya qué
plazo
eso es previsión financiera otra cosa
que es previsión financiera es habernos
endeudar
vivimos en el mundo del crédito en donde
nos están metiendo la pata a nosotros
mismos nosotros mismos y otros sin
educación financiera es bien difícil que
la inclusión financiera en verdad pueda
penetrar por qué pues porque facilitan
el adquirir nuevos productos financieros
incluidas inversiones
las islas usarlas
cuanto me pueden doblar sencillo
esos gastos fijos estos son sus gastos
variables espero que estés ahorrando por
lo menos el 20% de lo que ganas porque
el 20 morís para que ahorres por números
en 10
porque si le tiras al viento va a
ahorrar nada
deuda el 30 por ciento lo que ganas los
bancos les gusta el 40 el 40 se más
mucho
y otra cosa definitivamente si alguien
de ustedes aquí no ha aprendido sobre
seguros durante la pandemia perdón
tienes que aprender
he visto cuentas que van desde 300 mil
pesos hasta 13 millones de pesos por
coín
está estudiando emergencia
aprender cómo funciona los seguros y por
qué esto significa tener previsión
financiera
maurice es que me choca porque siento
que estoy tirando el dinero no lo está
estirando cuánto cuesta dormir tranquilo
en casa
cuanto cuesta dormir tranquilo pone lana
eso
decisión financiera número 4 que tenemos
que tomar en pandemia decide tener una
segunda fuente de ingresos no sé si
ustedes ya estén trabajando pero este es
el momento
para en verdad buscar tener una segunda
fuente ingreso ya nos sacaron de nuestra
zona de confort no vuelvan
no vuelvan les voy a platicar la
historia de pepe también es parte de mi
comunidad
pepe que hoy es empleado muy al
principio de comunidad
es empleado muy a principios de pandemia
y pp
porque estaba muy desmotivado y justo
cuando está hablando con él le decía
platícame que haces en tus tiempos
libres que estás haciendo ahorita la paz
de haber osado tiempo no y resulta que
él es un violinista muy buen violinista
así que le dije oye
el pasito puede ser clases en este
tiempo a la par puedes estar aplicando
otros
bueno pues ahorita está terminando el
año de pandemia casi casi empezando su
academia de violín y aparte ha consiguió
trabajo
qué estás haciendo en el tiempo
existen tomando clases porque están
tomando clases virtuales a que te
inclinas naturalmente saben a qué me
inclinaba yo naturalmente cuando
trabajaba a explicar finanzas
porque una amiga me grababa no me da
cuenta que me grababa y los subiera
redes sociales y resulta que la gente le
gustó
inclinas naturalmente hacer
y la decisión número 5
esta pandemia es para empezar
para empezar
para empezar aquí
a tomar conciencia de las finanzas
número 2 aterrizar las definitivamente
tener conciencia financiera
número 2 sobre todo en verdad que es un
parteaguas en nuestra vida yo lo voy a
practicar una historia muy personal
bueno las crisis empujan los cambios
que eran necesarios pero dejamos para
después porque porque si yo vuelta la
cuenta de banco y hay lana no pasa nada
es hasta cuándo empieza a escasear que
nos preocupamos que nos administramos
esta crisis nos está afectando a
cualquier rubro en nuestra vida la forma
en que nos relacionamos con nuestros
seres queridos la forma en que tenemos
la forma en que tenemos aspiraciones y
metas
entonces las crisis empujan los cambios
que eran necesarios pero dejábamos
yo que descubrí en la pandemia es que yo
descubrí un don precioso que sé
describir
y bueno escribiendo
voy a sacar un segundo libro ahora el
próximo semestre ya me puse el objetivo
un libro al año
que te enseño a la pandemia acuerdate no
es una catástrofe vivir una crisis
y con crisis como refiero a la pandemia
me referí a cualquier tipo de crisis la
catástrofe es no haber aprendido nada de
ella
qué tal el mundo digital para todos los
emprendedores que quiere empezar un
negocio desde este momento este es el
momento para aprender marketing digital
este es el momento para hacer los
negocios en línea este es el momento
vivimos somos de la generación de la
tecnología este es el momento así que
esto es ahorita les pregunto y ustedes y
quiero que escriban todos los están
tomando notas que te comprometes a
empezar
y en verdad les quiero invitar
a que hagan de este llamado emergencia
algo que en verdad si un parteaguas en
su vida creo que esta conferencia es el
primer día del resto de su vida
financiera
esta conferencia
les voy decir algo
porque si no lo toman aquí perdón pero
no lo van a ver en ningún lado
pregúntate que te está regalando la
pandemia
creatividad espacios
qué te está regalando la pandemia
consideren esto su llamado a emergencias
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]